rent groceries even the cost of heating
your home is skyrocketing everything
seems more expensive these days so what
can be done to save a little money
there's only one person to talk to Mr
Wonderful he's an entrepreneur you know
him from Shark Tank Kevin O'Leary nice
to have you back on Good Day New York
thank you so much wonderful to be here
um you know I know that you you know how
to skirt things I mean you you came from
Canada right and you've developed quite
a great big business and your your
tentacles are kind of everywhere right I
mean a lot of things these days that's
right so let's talk a little bit right
now because people are dealing with Con
Edison or their utility bills things are
high they are can you save a little
money with electricity what what can you
do it's tough because core inflation
electricity and food those are the two
which is energy gasoline electricity
they're really naggingly high above six
percent and they're staying there right
now the key is to be care careful of
what you spend every day and you know
it's sort of like when you go to buy
something and I tell my kids this too
because my mother taught me this there's
a lot of stuff you buy you don't need
you go look in your closet there's all
kinds of crap you bought you don't use
right well that's money that's dead so
if you're gonna buy something nice like
a coat or sweater or a new pair of pants
make sure it's really good quality and
buy one of them and use it like
absolutely where you know your Europeans
do that I noticed yes they'll buy one
really nice thing and they'll wear it to
death yeah so they buy fewer things
higher quality even their closets like
they have four pair of shoes not 40.
like it's it's sort of that's and if you
look at what you wear most of the time
I've got two pair of jeans I've got
these suits which my Shark Tank outfit
I've got 25 of these jackets because I
wear them out so much but I never change
my outfit it's like a uniform but I know
what I'm spending all the time and even
very wealthy families and I've tell
everybody to try this take a piece of
paper you don't need a computer write
down the money you made in three months
90 days and on the other piece of paper
how much you spent in the same 90 days
most people outspend their income even
wealthy families it's a great exercise
and where does that debt end up on
credit cards at 21 so if you're not
paying off your credit card you're
paying 21 interest this is is the killer
in America the silent killer that's what
I call it you've got to spend within
your means suck it up and do it so
really save save but I mean how do you
how do you do it without even save us
don't spend what you don't have it's
that simple right right if you can't
afford it you can't afford it I know but
you know Kevin you go into the grocery
store everything's up but you know you
still got to buy the eggs and the butter
and the bread for your family this is
Staples but that means you give up on
something else maybe you don't buy that
pair of sneakers maybe you don't buy
another piece of clothes maybe you cool
it on the car you do not want to spend
beyond your means that's my message
today do not do that I noticed so that
you even though you're talking about
like you know try to save whatever way
you can with your utilities you like to
invest in utility companies do and
credit card companies I mean if you're
I've tell people do not let me make
money off interest on my credit card
companies do not let me do that don't
ever carry a balance forward you're
paying me 21 interest that's crazy but
people do that isn't insane all right
speaking of making money because you do
like to do that on Shark Tank you've got
like this new invention yes that I was
like why didn't I think of that look at
this tell us what that is this when I
saw this on Shark Tank it's called the
wad free right and what this does is it
stops your sheets from wadding up in the
dryer you dry them 15 sooner and faster
saving 20 energy and this is the new wad
fee version that does duvets and big
towels so what you just throw it in the
dryer you take you clip the corners of
the sheet or the duvet yeah into these
you just put it through and just push it
like that and seal it to this and this
stops it from bunching up that's the
whole idea it's a very simple idea are
you making money on this one huge huge
hit on Shark Tank well apparently it's
it's running from 20 to 55 at
wadfree.com yeah depending what you get
but you save so much money on energy a
wad phrase saves you money the minute
you start using it
at home and I sowed it to my wife I said
look at this you know you throw in a
sheet it gets all bunched up yeah yeah
and it sits there turning never dry
right that never happens with a wad free
it stops it that's why it's called wad
free it's so simple there she is
pitching on Shark Tank that was the
first version this is the new
multitasking big one and I showed it to
Linda and she said that's ingenious
right now what you think of that I know
I don't know why I didn't think about it
either but you know listen you can't
always be right Kevin no I know that you
can't always be right and perhaps you
were a little wrong with saying that you
were a spokesperson for FTX
but I want to tell you something about
Venture investing okay eight and since
the beginning of time since 1954 when
they started tracking Venture investing
in the United States out in Boston
eight out of ten deals fail within three
years and two make you a thousand times
on your money like a wad free is a
winner we know that right but other
deals are going to fail FTX was just
another startup a big one but a
catastrophic failure but it doesn't
change what I do tomorrow morning yes I
lost 18 million dollars I don't like
that I think you made some money with
him didn't he pay you like a million or
15 million 18 million but he paid you 18
yeah and I put it back into FTX in the
stock and into the account and all the
money was swept out of everybody's
account on FTX we all lost our money I
had to pay the IRS taxes and agents and
everything else but look I look like an
idiot and so do all the other investors
but look we didn't anticipate this who
knew who knew yeah I mean even up to
this even up to this point I'm like
thinking this guy has gotten a lot of
free passes who is he because supposedly
he's been accused of yes uh tampering
with the jury which is uh or a witness
which would get you thrown back in jail
while you're awaiting trial he's got a
trial of waiting here's the thing here's
the good news the narrative on FTX has
changed they've now found out of the 8
billion missing 6.1 of it so this is a
situation where some people are going to
get some money back it's going to go to
have to go through the bag it's like
Madoff yeah but they threw Madoff in
jail right away why is this kid not in
jail he's got to go to trial you know
he's got to go to trial so at the end of
the day all of this is happening but
people are starting to ask okay I had a
thousand dollars in my account I had a
million dollars in my account where's my
money well it looks like we don't know
it's all alleged at this point that
almost 60 percent of it's been found so
let's see what happens next okay you
think you're going to be called as a
witness don't know I've already been to
the Senate I went to the Senate hearings
about it
um and I testified everything I knew and
you know I hope I'm I'm very hopeful
that people get a large portion of their
money back that's really the of course
and you know for those of us that are
you know investors we know this stuff
happens it's bad I know Kevin O'Leary I
could talk to you all day and night I'm
going to watch you on Shark Tank because
you're fabulous you are Mr Wonderful and
um
you know Cindy braised her name when I
saw her on the set it was such a tasty
solution why didn't I think
I've heard enough I want a deal I want a
deal because I know I can sell a lot of
these and I am and she's doing a great
job Denver out of Denver Colorado Cindy
keep up the good work one free everybody
save a ton of money on energy that's it
Kevin uh O'Leary Mr Wonderful check him
out on the Shark Tank